thank you thank you
Tarek good morning good afternoon and
good evening everywhere you are when the
nations of the world met to form the
United Nations in 1945 one of the first
things they discussed was establishing
an organization to protect and promote
the health of the world's people they
express that desire in the constitution
of whu-oh which says that the enjoyment
of the highest attainable standard of
Health is one of the fundamental rights
of every human being without distinction
of race religion political belief
economic or social condition that Creed
remains our vision today the United
States of America has been a
long-standing and generous friend to
whu-oh and we hope it will continue to
be so we regret the decision of the
President of the United States to order
a halt in funding to the World Health
Organization we support from the people
and government of the United States W
works to improve the health of many of
the world's poorest and most vulnerable
people WH o is not only fighting covet
19 we are also working to address polio
measles malaria Ebola HIV tuberculosis
malnutrition cancer diabetes mental
health and many other diseases and
conditions we also work with countries
to strengthen health systems and improve
access to life-saving health services
w-h-o is reviewing the
part of our work of any withdrawal of US
funding and we work with our partners to
fill any financial gaps we face and to
ensure our work continues uninterrupted
our commitment to public health signs
and to serving all the people of the
world without fear or favor remains
absolute our mission and mandate art
work with all nations equally without
regard to size of their populations or
economies covet 19 does not discriminate
between rich nations and poor large
nations and small it does not
discriminate between nationalities
ethnicities or ideologies neither do we
this is a time for all of us to be
united in our common struggle against a
common threat a dangerous enemy when we
are divided the virus exploits the
cracks between us we are committed to
serving the world's people and to
accountability for the resources with
which we are entrusted in due course
double H's performance in tackling this
pandemic will be reviewed by LWS Member
States and the independent bodies that
are in place to ensure transparency and
accountability for that matter involving
all responders this is part of the usual
process put in place by our member
states no doubt areas for improvement
will be identified and there will be
lessons for all of us to learn but for
now our focus my focus is on stopping
this virus and saving lives whu-oh is
grateful to the many nations
organizations and individuals who have
expressed their support and commitment
to de Blasio in recent days including
their financial commitment we welcome
this demonstration of global solidarity
because solidarity is the rule of the
game to defeat covet 19w Joe is getting
on with the job we're continuing to
study this virus every moment of every
day we're learning from many countries
about what works and we are sharing that
information with the world there are
more than 1.5 million enrollments in wh
was online courses through open WH
or.org and we will continue to expand
this platform to train many more
millions so we can fight kovat
effectively